[Music]
hallo YouTube Ches Louis in la France
this is Gungan here welcome to my 30th
episode of chest strap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap as well as
counter trap in the TV echo Grand Prix
attack from both the colors the opening
arises after the falling water evil c5
Knight to c3 Knight to c6 and now this
modern move Bishop to b5 so idea is very
simple what white wants to do is he
wants to chop up this Knight give black
a double pawn and then continue with his
grunty attack on the kingside which as
per the database
turn out very well so obviously a black
shouldn't allow this and accordingly
Knight to d4 is a fitting reply counter
attacking the bishop and certainly why
doesn't want to give up the bishop pair
so Bishop to c4 is the obvious choice
now here it doesn't matter whether black
continued with Knight to f6 or a six
let's say a6 is the most popular choice
white plan up campaign is very simple
what he wants to do is first play Knight
G to e2 and as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows the simple but
effective plan of campaign is castle
then throw your F pawn which gives wide
a good King side attack okay black can
choose either of the moves such as
Knight to f6 or 97 it doesn't matter as
after let's say the most popular choice
Knight to f6 which has a clear intention
to play the move d5 and surprisingly
enough white is going to ignore it and
castle on the Kings side
well we reach to the most critical
position of this line and here one move
leads to the trap and the other move
leads to the counter trap so let's see
each pattern the first obvious move I
want to consider is D Phi which is so
natural as after II kept his D Phi and
the MU II kept his D Phi not only black
get the space at the center of the board
but white pieces get pushed back and
what can be the more natural than this
and yes everything looks so good for the
black except one problem that black has
straightaway fallen into the white trapa
territory in fact there are five GM and
few International Master on fallen into
this trap so you can see the potential
of this line here what has this stunning
reply did you spot it yup it's Knight
captures D Phi boom ha ha ha ha what a
move so at first sight this looks
completely impossible right
because scant black just simply take
this piece and asking why hey what are
you doing well see yourself as the
critical sequence continue with Knight
captures d4 pawn captures d4 and now the
sting and the tail Queen to h5 and not
only this Queen is attacking the knight
but the knight can't move as Queen
captures f7 leads to the checkmate well
black has the only response namely
Bishop to e6 defending every single
threat but now comes Luke to even hand
no matter however black wriggles he get
unlost position the threat is very
simple white wants to play rook captures
c6 as the f7 pawn his pin and the other
threat
white can also play the move Queen
captures defer as this Bishop is now pen
down even after the best response by
black namely Bishop to e7 we get this
forcing sequence which gives white a
completely upper hand first rook
captures c6 getting of a piece back and
the critical response continue with g6
counter-attacking
two major guys White has the equally
good response namely Queen to e5 looking
the juicy rook in the corner so black
responds his force black has to first
save the rook with rook to g8 but after
rook captures e7 Knight captures a 7 yes
indeed for a time being it looks like
black is an exchanger
but after just one move d3 and by force
what is getting that night in a star
King can't move as bishop at 6 check
force King to come back and the accurate
response GFI completely fails due to the
weary of this move Bishop captures defy
and now it is black who has to give the
exchange back if he wants to save the
night so rook captures defy Queen
captures defile and at the end of the
whole transaction you can easily see not
only white emerge with a 2 extra pawn
but plaquing is completely caught at the
center and a spurred engine this is a
decisive advantage to the white camp so
this is one of the wonderful trap exists
if your opponent played the moon early
defy
okay so now let's see what is the
counter trap and the counter trap start
with this very cute move asics so idea
is very simple black wants to grab space
on the Quinn side and here it doesn't
matter whether white continue with a4 or
d3 let's say a4 is better choices but
then black can play this trap EMU d5 so
you might laugh at this and saying well
what's the difference I can go for the
same trap right so he captures Levi he
captures d5 Knight captures defy and
this is all we have seen earlier right
after Queen to h5 Bishop to e6 and rook
to e1 it doesn't look like scenario has
been changed except this a 6 and e4 has
been inserted
so what huge difference that can make
but the smarter people can find the
difference and the use difference is now
black and play this superb move Knight
to f4 attacking the Queen obviously
I guess now you can see the difference
that if this a 6mu has not been played
then white has this lethal Bishop b5
check which help why to gain the piece
back after King to e7 and queen to G if
I check but as of now it's not possible
that means white has to do something in
order to avoid losing a piece the best
response goes as follows rook captures
c6 check so why it sacrifice an exchange
in order to get at least a piece back
and here black can play the Moon Knight
captures ecigs but I found this better
continuation namely Bishop to e7 keep
attacking these two big guys so again
that leads to the force response rook
captures e7 Queen captures e7
at the end of the sequence you can
easily see not only black is an
exchanger up against Bishop and pawn but
right now there's a threat on Queen and
Queen to even can also create some huge
problems for the white camp all in all
with accurate play this is a winning
position for the black camp that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and like this
wonderful trap and counter trap in the
TV aku Grand Prix attack thank you for
watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
you